[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج الى العناوين
وزير خارجيه ايراني يؤكد التزاما الالتزام
باستقرار المنطقه ويعلن الاتفاق مع
السعوديه على زياره وفود فنيه لفتح
السفارات
على وقع التوتر بين البرلمان والحكومه
الكويت تعيد مجلس الامه المنتخب عام 2020
ورئيسه السابق مرزوق الغانم
عبر 15 مسارا واكثر من 600 محطه اطلاق
المرحله الاولى من خدمات حافلات الرياض
في الرابعه ايضا
في قطر النائب العام يامر باحاله وزير
الماليه السابق ومسؤولين اخرين الى محكمه
الجنايات لمواجهه تهامي بالفساد
المحكمه العليا في السعوديه تدعو لتحريه
الى شهر رمضان الثلاثاء والمدينه المنوره
تضع خططا للافطار والتنقل
نبدا من اخر التصريحات المتعلقه بالاتفاق
السعودي الايراني حيث قال وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبداللهيان انه سيلتقي
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان قريبا مشيرا الى انه تم اقتراحه
ثلاثه اماكن لعقد الاجتماع واضاف وزير
خارجيه ايران انه تم الاتفاق مع السعوديه
على زياره وفود فنيه لسفارتين تحضيرا
لاعاده فتحهما وبشان اليمن قال عبد
اللهيان ان الازمه شان داخلي لكن ايران
تؤكد على الامن المستقر في المنطقه بتعاون
مع السعوديه ايضا اضاف ان ايران لن تقبل
اي تهديد امني يكون منطلقه الاراضي
العراقيه
العراق وقع اتفاقيه امنياء مشتركه مع
ايران في حضور رئيس الوزراء محمد الشياع
السوداني وذكر مكتب رئيس الوزراء العراقي
انه اكد خلال لقائه رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني علي شمخاني اكد موقفا
بلاده الرافض لان تكون الاراضي العراقيه
منطلقا للاعتداء على اي من دول الجوار
واضاف البيان ان الاتفاق الامني المشترك
بين طهران وبغداد يهدف للتنسيق وحمايه
الحدود بين البلدين وتوطيد التعاون في
مجالات امنيه عده
تعهد وزير العدل الالماني ماركو بوشمان
باعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في
حال قرر الاخير زياره المانيا وذلك
امتثالا لقرار محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وقال بوشمان في تصريحات نشرتها وسائل
اعلام المانيه ان محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
ستتواصل مع الانتربول لمطالبه الدول
الاعضاء بالامتثال لمذكره الاعتقال
الصادره بحق بوتين مشيرا الى ان المانيا
ستطبق هذه المذكره وستحترم اختصاص محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه
هذا وتتولا ردود الفعل الدوليه على اصدار
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال
بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين جنوب
افريقيا اكدت انها تدرك التزاماتها
القانونيه اذا زار بوتين جوهان لحضور قمه
المقرره في اغسطس المقبل وقال المتحدث
باسم الرئيس السيريل راما فوزا ان جنوب
افريقيا ستتعامل مع كافه الجهات المعنيه
بخصوص زياره بوتين المحتمله
في الاثناء قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين انه لا يزال يتعين على بلاده بدل
المزيد من الجهود لتطوير قواتها العسكريه
واوضح بوتين في تصريحات صحفيه انه على
الرغم من امتلاك روسيا اسلحه فرض صوتيه
لكنها لا تستخدمها وشدد بوتين على قوه
النظام المالي في روسيا رغم توقعات الدول
الغربيه بانهياره وفي الشان الاوكراني
اضاف بوتين ان روسيا لم تستطع ان ترفض طلب
دعم سكان شبهي جزيره القرم عام 2014 وجدد
الرئيس الروسي تاكيده ان روسي انطلقت
سلميا ولم ترغب
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين ان رحلات
الطيران من دون طيار الامريكيه فوق بحر
البلطيق هي علامه واضحه على تورط الولايات
المتحده وبشكل مباشر في الصراع الجاري مع
اوكرانيا ضد روسيا واضاف بسكوب انما تقوم
به تلك المسيرات ليست مهمه سلميه وان
مشغلي تلك الطائرات من دون طيار يشاركون
في الصراع ضد موسكو
قال امينو مجلس الامن القومي الايراني علي
شمخاني ان التطبيق الكامل لوثيقه الاتفاق
الامني مع العراق سيضع حدا لتحركات عناصر
وصفها بالمناهضه لامن طهران جاء ذلك خلال
زيارته الى بغداد ولقائه مستشار الامن
الوطني العراقي قاسم الاعرجي حيث اشار
ايضا الى ان الوثيقه التي تم توقيعها
رسميا بين البلدين جرى بحثها منذ عده اشهر
من جانب كبار المسؤولين الامنيين في
البلدين
ذكرت مصادر العربيه ان الرئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني سيبدا
الثلاثاء زياره الى تركيا تستمر يومين
واشارت المصادر الى ان السودان سيناقش في
تركيا عددا من الملفات اهمها ضبط الحدود
والمياه وانتشار حزب العمال الكردستاني
على الاراضي العراقيه وملفات سياسيه
واقتصاديه وقال رئيس الوزراء العراقي خلال
مؤتمر حوار بغداد ان بلاده استعادت دورها
حاضنه للحوارات ومكانتها اقليميا ودوليا
العراق استعاد مكانته الطبيعيه
حاضنا للحوارات والمؤتمرات
والفعاليات بمختلف
مسمياته ولن نتهاون هنا مع اي تراجع او
تلكه او خلل قد يتسبب باستغلال مال الشعب
لمصالح ذاتيه او حزبيه او فئويه فالثروه
الوطنيه ملك ملك العراقيين جميعا
عاما يمر على الغزو الامريكي للعراق الغزو
الذي اطاح بنظام الرئيس السابق صدام حسين
خلق ايضا تركيبه سياسيه مختلفه باتت تسيطر
على العراق منذ ذلك
[موسيقى]
بعد عقدين من الزمن ما زالت تركيبه
السياسيه على حالها في العراق حتى مع
التغيير اتجاهاتها ومسمياتها الكتله
السياسيه الشيعيه المستفيد الاول من سقوط
نظام صدام حسين قبل 20 عاما وتكون حصه
الاسد من نصيبها في نظام ما بعد صدام فهي
اليوم باتت تمسك بمفاصل المشهد السياسي
برمته في العراق وتحت رقابه الحليفه ايران
وسط توازن هش ومتقلب محليا وحتى اقليميا
الصوره تبدو واضحه في الفضاء العام سواء
بصور رجال الدين العراقيين وغير العراقيين
المنتشره في كل الشوارع او من خلال احياء
المناسبات الدينيه التي كانت تقام بالسر
قبل عام 2003 هيمنه على الحياه السياسيه
بعد حرمان دام لفتره طويله من التمثيل
السياسي في ظل النظام القديم الذي اطاحت
به واشنطن حيث شرعت السلطات المؤقته التي
نصبتها الولايات المتحده في بناء نظام
سياسي جديد مع حلفائها واقامه توازن هش
للسلطه القائم على المحاصصه وتوزيع
المناصب بشكل رئيسي بين الشيعه والاكراد
والسنه مع نسب صغيره لبعض الاقليات
الدينيه والقوميه
طيله هذه الفتره هيمنه الاسماء نفسها على
البيت الشيعي وهي التسميه التي اطلقها
المراقبون على الطبقه السياسيه التقليديه
من نور المالك وهادي العامري وعمار الحكيم
والقائمه تطول كما ان اساسيات النظام لم
تتغير الى حد كبير فالقواعد التي ارسلتها
النخبه في عام 2003 وحتى 2005 ما زالت
تحكم الحياه السياسيه حتى الان
تضارب المصالح والبحث عن النفوذ داخل
اركان البيت الشعير دفع الخلافات للظهور
الى العلن لتبلغ ذروتها في اعقاب
الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره في عام 2021
لتتحول بعدها الى صدام مسلح على اسوار
المنطقه الخضراء في اغسطس 2022 بيوم من
القتال الدم في بغداد وما زال معظم
العراقيين الذين ولدوا بعد عام 2003 يمنون
النفس بدوله يحكمها القانون لينعموا
بخيرات هذا البلد الذي لم يعرف طعم
الاستقرار منذ زمن ليس بالقصير
كيف سقط نظام صدام حسين في العشرين من
مارس 2003 بدات الحرب التي اطلق عليها
الامريكيون عمليه حريه العراق نشر نحو 150
الف جندي امريكي واربعين الف جنديين
بريطاني في العراق
سماء بغداد تحولت الى كره نار ضخمه بعد
عمليات القصف الامريكي البريطانيه
اصبحت الحرب حربا جويه بامتياز وصلت
غاراتها الى القصر الرئاسي
الخامس والعشرون من مارس عبر 4000 جندي من
المارينز مدينه الناصريه
الحادي والثلاثون من مارس معركه بريه وقعت
بين العسكريين الامريكيين مع وحدات من
الحرس الجمهوري العراقي
الرابع من ابريل استولى الامريكيون على
مطار بغداد بعد معارك طاحنه مع قوات الحرس
الجمهوري
السابع من ابريل
استولى التحالف الدولي على ثلاثه قصور
رئاسيه في بغداد
التاسع من ابريل 2003 انهار النظام
العراقي وسيطر الامريكيون على العاصمه
بغداد
انتزع تمثال صدام حسين بدبابات امريكيه من
قاعدته
الاول من مايو 2003 اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
نهايه المعارك ومواصله الحرب ضد الارهاب
من اربيل ينضم الينا الكاتب والباحث
السياسي كفاح محمود اهلا بك معنا سيد كفاح
اذا منذ 20 عام منذ الاطاحه بحكم صدام
حسين وحتى اليوم الذي تغير في المشهد
السياسي العراقي تحديدا
بدايه سيدتي الله كريمه السيده فاطمه
احييك
بالتاكيد تغيرت الامور كثيره لكن ليست
بالضروره ان تكون قد تغيرت نحو الافضل
وهذا حقيقه هذا هو المؤلم
انا كنت شاهد عيان منذ اللحظات الاولى
لسقوط النظام وحتى قبل سقوط النظام
كنا جميعا بكل شرائح المجتمع قومياته
اذيانه مذاهبه بانتظار
تحرير البلاد وليس اسقاط الدوله ما حصل هو
اسقاط الدوله مع اسقاط صدام حسين ونظامه
وهذا الذي ارعبنا منذ الساعات الاولى كما
قلت لك حينما بدات عمليات السلب والنهب في
كل مؤسسات الدوله ابتداء من معسكرات الجيش
ودوائر
الامن والبقيه دوائر الدوله المتاحف
لم يتركوا شيئا بل حطم الكثير حتى محطات
المياه
محطات الكهرباء بمعنى انه كان هناك برنامج
لاسقاط الدوله وليس اسقاط صدام حسين فقط
وهذا ما اعطى مؤشر خطير جدا في في بدايه
الاحداث للاسف الشديد جميعنا يعني كنا
نتامل ان الايام اللاحقه او الاشهر
القادمه ربما ستتغير الصوره
وتاتي نخب وطنيه لقياده البلاد
وتعويضها عما فاتها من حروب ومعاشي وكوارث
طيله اكثر من نصف قرن من 1958 وحتى 2003
لكن للاسف الشديد اليوم
حينما تقرئين المشهد الاجتماعي والسياسي
والاقتصادي للبلاد يصاب الانسان باحباط
كبير العراق الان هذا الذي يصدر ما يزيد
على اربعه ملايين برميل يوميا هناك اكثر
من عشره ملايين عاطل عن العمل هناك نسبه
الفقر التي يقترب من اربعين بالمئه من
مجموع السكان هناك البطاله المنتشره يعني
اسباب عده ادت الى هذا المشهد في العراق
كما تتحدث حضرتك ولكن داعش ايضا كان لهم
دور كبير خصوصا ربما في اربيل يعني كان
هناك تصريحات لقائد العمليات المشتركه في
العراق المحمداوي قال فيها بان داعش ما
زال موجود ولو انه اضعف مما كان ولكنه ما
زال موجود وسيتحتم وقت طويل لانهائه ما
رايك في هذا الكلام وما دور داعش في وضع
العراق الداخلي الان
بالضبط وليس داعش لوحده يعني دعينا نكون
واقعيين ونضع اصابعنا على مكامل الالم
داعش والميليشيات والفصائل المنفلته التي
تقوم هي الاخرى بذات الافعال التي كانت
تقوم بها داعش داعش هناك خطا كبير وقع فيه
كثير من الاعلاميين وحتى وسائل الاعلام
يعني اوهم الراي العام بانه تم تطهير
العراق من داعش وهذا الذي حصل في سوريا
ايضا لكن حقيقه الامر نجحت القوات المسلحه
العراقيه في تحطيم هيكل داعش العسكري
وتحولت داعش بعد ذلك الى خلايا نائمه ما
لم تلبس الا فتره قليله وعادت مره اخرى
بعملياتها النوعيه طبعا داعش انتجت الكثير
من الدواعش بتسميات اخرى وهنا اقصت هذه
الفصائل والميليشيات التي تعبث بالبلاد من
سنجار وحتى البصره وتهيمن على كثير من
مفاصل الدوله الاقتصاديه والامنيه
والسياسيه وهذا ما يرعب يعني يرعب المراقب
ويثير كثير من الشكوك حتى في المستقبل
يعني دائما انا اقول قلتها مع السيد
الكاظمي وقولها مع السيد السوداني ان
حملهم ثقيل مع جل الاحترام لكل جهودهم
لكنهم سيواجهون هذه التحديات الكبيره سواء
في الخلايا النائمه تحت الارض المتمثله
بداعش والمنظمات الارهابيه الدينيه
المتطرفه دعيني استخدم هذه التعبير السنيه
يقابلها تطرف اخر لفصائل وميليشيات متطرفه
ومتشدده لا تقل افعالها بشاعه من داعش وهي
تعبث كما قلت لك فوق الارض وداعش تحت
الارض في نهايه المعادله الخاسر الوحيد
الذي يدفع الفاتوره هو المواطن شكرا لك من
اربيل الكاتب والباحث السياسي كفاح محمود
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون
الغاء 110 صكوك على بحر جده لامراء ووزراء
ورجال اعمال خالفوا الانظمه المعتمده
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد ابطلت المحكمه
الدستوريه في الكويت انتخابات مجلس الامه
لعام 2022
وقررت اعاده مجلس الامه المنتخب عام 20 20
والذي كان رئيسه مرزوق الغانم المحكمه قضت
بان يستعيد المجلس السابق المنحل سلطته
الدستوريه من تاريخ هذا الحكم كان الحل لم
يكن وياتي هذا القرار في وقت تجددت فيه
التوترات بين البرلمان والحكومه حيث علقت
الحكومه حضورها لجلسات مجلس الامه
[موسيقى]
من الكويت انضم الينا استاذ القانون
الدستوري الدكتور محمد الفيلي اهلا بك
معنا الدكتور في نشره الرابعه يعني هذا
الحكم الذي صدر ما تفاصيله وعلى ماذا
يستند او على ماذا استندت المحكمه
الدستوريه في ابطال المجلس الحالي والعوده
الى مجلس عشرين عشرين
سيدتي الفاضله اولا تحيه لك ولمن يتابع
الحوار
من الناحيه الفنيه كي تجرى انتخابات في اي
برلمان يجب ان ينتهي الفصل التشريعي اما
نهايه مقتصره او نهايه عاديه ولا يجوز ان
تجر انتخابات والمجلس قائم فاذا قررت
المحكمه عدم سلامه الحل فهذا يعني ان
المجلس كان قائما ولا يزال قائما وبالرغم
من ذلك اجريت انتخابات اذا هذه النقطه
التي تنطلق منها او انطلقت منها المحكمه
في هذا الحكم
من الناحيه الفنيه هي اخذت بتوجه
استخدمته في 2012 في اول حكم ببطلان
المجلس اذا نحن امام توجه له سوابق ولكن
به تطوير ان في 2012 كانت تقول يجب ان
يكون هناك سبب تقول يجب ان يكون هناك سبب
بمواصفات مع
ما هي
اثار هذا الحكم وما هو يعني ما هي دلالاته
هو الدلاله خارج علال العلاقه بين السلطات
نحن في مكان ما امام توسيع نطاق الرقابه
للقضاء على اعمال السلطات العامه بغض
النظر من هو الخاسر ومن هو الكاتب من
السياسيين
فكره توزيع
نطاق الرقابه على اعمال السلطات العامه هو
شكل من اشكال تقويه فكره دوله القانون هل
هناك مرحله تقاضي اخرى فوق المحكمه
الدستوريه ام هذا الحكم
هي درجه واحده
ولا يمكن اعاده تقديم
البعن
الا باجراء انتخابات جديده طيب ذهبت قرابه
السنه من برلمان 2020 دكتور يعني هل هذه
السنه تعوض لهم ليكملوا السنوات او سنوات
منطوق الحكم كانما قالت الزمن توقفت ثم
نحركها من حيث توقفت منذ صدور مرسوم الحل
منذ صدور مرسوم الحل الى الان مضى ما يزيد
على سته اشهر اكثر
ثمانيه اشهر احنا امام الان
معضله جديده من الناحيه الفنيه وهي قابله
للحل اللي هي دكتور يقول الدستور يقول مده
الفصل التشريعي اربع سنوات لا تزيد الا في
حاله الحرب وبصدوق قانون اذا هذه هذا
الشرط الدستوري غير
متواجد في مبادئ عامه تقول عندما يكون
هناك وقف لسبب لا اراده للاطراف يجب الا
يحتسب من الميعاد
قيد الحل الاكثر حصافه حتى نبتعد عن
مفاجات في اي اتجاه المحكمه الدستوريه في
الكويت تملك اختصاص بتفسير
النصوص الدستوريه وهنا نص دستوريه يحدد
مده الفصل التشريعي
طلب تفسير من
وبهذا سواء لان هذا يهم المجلس
فيهم الحكومه في فضل دور للانعقاد وفي فض
الفصل التشريعي اذا من المصلحه ان تذهب
الحكومه بطلب التفسير هذا طيب واضح طيب
دكتور افهم منك يعني لا يلزم اعاده
انتخابات بالتالي
حاليا نحن امام مجلس قائم
الحكم ليس له علاقه بالحكومه الحكومه التي
استقالت والان هي بصدد التشكيل هي الحكومه
القائمه وهي التي يلزم عليها التعامل مع
المجلس واضح طب اجراءات التنفيذ دكتور كيف
ستكون متى ستطبق يعني يوم الثلاثاء القادم
المفترض في جلسه هل ستقام
نعم الان اولا من الناحيه الفنيه
والتصور ان هذا الدم يجب
ابلاغ رئيس المجلس الذي تم حل بالحكم حتى
يصبح الحكم نافذ لمواجهته بعد ذلك هو يدعو
الاجتماع واظن ان هذا الامر تم بدليل الان
في خبر
شائع يتكلم عن دعوه الاجتماع يوم الثلاثاء
افترض من الخبر صحيح وهذا يعني ان تم
اخباره بالحكم
الحكومه يجب ان تحضر امام هذا المجلس
اذا ارادت ان تشارك في اعمال
واذا ارادت ان تحله وفق الحكم الجديد لا
يتاتى لها ذلك الا اذا حضرت امامك اذا
حضرت امامه سوف تقسم كي تستطيع ان تمارس
عملها باعتبارها عضو في مجلس الامه هذه من
المسائل التي يقررها الدستور الكويتي وهذا
السبب الذي اخذته عليه عليها المحكمه في
الواقع شكرا لك من الكويت استاذ القانون
الدستوري دكتور محمد الفيلي
وحول ابطال مجلس الامه الكويتيه المنتخب
عام 20 22 ينضم الينا ايضا من الكويت
المحلل السياسي احمد العيسى اهلين اهلا بك
معنا استاذ احمد يعني برايك ماذا ستكون
تداعيات هذا الحكم على المشهد السياسي
الحالي وعلى العلاقه بين السلطتين كذلك
والله هو بدايه يعني يجب بالتاكيد على ان
مساله ابطال المحكمه الدستوريه لمجالس
الامه او مراسيم حلم مجالس الامه او يعني
او ما ترتب عليها اليوم احنا قاعد نتكلم
على ثالث مرسوم خلال عشر سنوات من اصل ست
مجالس على مدى العشر سنوات اللي فاتت ثلاث
مجالس منهم ابطلتهم المحكمه الدستوريه بما
فيهم مجلس 2022 بحكم بالحكم الصادر اليوم
واضح ان المحكمه الدستوريه تحاول ان ترسل
رساله للحكومه ومتخذ القرار بان اجراءات
الحل يجب ان تكون متماشيه مع الدستور ويجب
ان تكون متماشيه مع الاجراءات واللواء
واحلالنا في الحالتين السابقتين في
المرحله في
2012 في حكم المحكمه الدستوريه الصادر في
16 يونيو كان واضح ان الحكومه التي رفعت
مرسوم الحل لا تملك الصفه لذلك وفي السنه
اللي بعدها ايضا ابطل المجلس الامه لقيام
الحكومه باتخاذ مجموعه من القرارات التي
لا تتطابق مع موضوع الضروره الذي نص عليه
الدستور واليوم احنا امام يبدو نفس الحاله
حينما تقول المحكمه الدستوريه بان يجب على
الحكومه ان تمارس اعمالها قبل ان تقرر
امكان التعاون او عدم التعاون مع هذا
المجلس الحكومه الحاليه تم تشكيلها في
واحد اغسطس وفي اليوم التالي قررت عدم
التعاون مع مجلس الامه شاهد اليوم ان هذا
الحكم انا هذا البرلمان او او عوده
البرلمان هل ستسهل تشكيل الحكومه الجديده
استاذ احمد يعني هل سنرى حكومه تصريف
الاعمال تحضر اجتماعات المجلس
انا شخصيا لا اعتقد حكومه تصريف العاجل
بالاعمال ستحضر هذا المجلس لسبب بسيط لان
اليوم احنا امام مواقع جديد وبناء عليه
يجب ان تتشكل حكومه جديده لكن الشاهد اللي
انا كنت ابي اوقف عنده بانه اليوم هذا
الحكم يجب ان ينظر له من زاويه مختلفه هذا
الحكم اليوم اصبح يؤكد بان حتى تصريح سمو
ولي العهد في 22 يونيو بان الحكومه ستقوم
باجراءات سليمه وتبحثها دستوريا وقانونيا
حتى لا يتم الطعن عليها اليوم المحكمه
الدستوريه قالت ان هذا الكلام غير صحيح
واجراءات ابطال او اجراءات حل مجلس الامه
السابق هي اجراءات غير قانونيه وغير سليمه
وكانوا من الاوجب ان تقوم الحكومه بكذا
وكان الاوجب ان تقوم الحكومه بكذا بمعنى
ان ايضا اليوم المساله تعدت القرار
الاداري الخاص او المرسوم الاداري الخاص
من الحكومه وتعدت ايضا الى التوجيهات
السياسيه ويمكن هذه القصه جت نتيجه خلاف
ايضا لمجموعه من النواب سواء كان مع رئيس
الحكومه السابق الشيخ صباح الخالد في مارس
الماضي او مع الاخ رئيس المرزوق الاخ
مرزوق الغانم رئيس مجلس وبالحديث عن هذه
الخلف مع رئيس البرلمان لعام 2020 استاذ
احمد يعني يعود وهل تعود معه الخلافات مع
بعض البرلمانيين يعني هناك تغريده لنائب
رئيس المجلس المنحل كان قال فيها ان عدتم
عدنا وليس شعار وانما هو وان رفعناها فيما
مضى وانما هو سلوك وناهج ولتغريدته المزيد
ما رايك وماذا نفهم من هذه التغريده
ست فاطمه العنتريات في العمل السياسي لا
يمكن ان تؤدي الى نتائج ممكن تطبيقها على
الارض اليوم المساله الاساسيه يجب ان يجلس
جميع الفرقاء على نفس الطاوله وينظروا في
مساله تحريك المسائل اليوم احنا امام
حكومه على مدى 70 يوم منذ انسحبت من جلسه
خمسه يناير لم تقم باجراء اي شيء سوى
زياده رواتب ومكافات اعضائها ووزرائها
وايضا نقل بعض المواطنين بما يتماشى مع
مصالح وزراءها السياسيه احنا في المقابل
لدينا مجموعه من النواب فضلوا ان يعني
تفضلوا توزيع الثروه الموجوده في الاحتياط
العام على المواطنين بدلا من انجاز قوانين
وايضا في يعني خلينا نقول في الوضع الاخر
او في المقلب الثاني لدينا اعضاء في مجلس
الامه السابق حاولوا ابتزاز الحكومه
ورئيسها وايضا هناك مجموعه تحالفت مع رئيس
مجلس الامه احنا اليوم نتكلم على وضع
سياسي لا يمكن الخروج منه بنصوص اليوم
الازمه هي ازمه النفوس ويجب ان يجلس جميع
الاطراف على نفس الطاوله وبحث امكانيه ما
يمكن بحثه بهدف وضع خارطه الطريق للمستقبل
انا اشوف اليوم هناك فسحه من الامل يجب
استثمارها وان شاء الله الامور في القادم
من الايام تكون افضل نتمنى ذلك من الكويت
المحلل السياسي احمد العيسى شكرا جزيلا لك
احاله النائب العام في قطر وزير الماليه
السابق علي شريف العمادي واخرين للمحكمه
الجنائيه في جرائم رشوه والاستيلاء على
المال العام واستغلال الوظيفه واساءه
استعمال السلطه وذكر بيان لنيابه العامه
القطريه ان التحقيقات اللازمه في هذه
القضيه انتهت بعد استجواب المتهمين وسماع
الشهود والاطلاع على التقارير الفنيه وان
ادله الاثبات المستخلصه متوفره وتؤكد
ارتكاب المتهمين الجرائم المستنده او
المستنده اليهم
اصدرت الجهات العدليه في جده قرارات
واوامر تقضي بالغاء نحو 110 صكوك وحجج
ملكيه لاراضي على بحر جده وذلك بعد ثبوت
استخراجها بشكل غير نظامي لا يستند الى
مخططات تنظيميه معتمده وبحسب صحيفه عكاظ
فان الصكوك الملغات تعود ملكيتها الى
امراء ووزراء سابقين ورجال وسيدات اعمال
وشركات واجهات حكوميه وخاصه اضافه الى
صكوك مجهوله ملكيه وكشفت مصادر عكاظ ان
اوامر الالغاء صدرت من المحكمه العليا عقب
دراسه الصكوك ورصد مخالفات عليها تستوجب
الغائها وما تفرع منها من صكوك
نشات الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون
خلل في انظمه العمل تعطل دخول 500 شاحنه
على الحدود السعوديه الاماراتيه وقلق من
تلف البضائع
وزير خارجيه ايران يؤكد الالتزام باستقرار
المنطقه ويعلن الاتفاق مع السعوديه على
زياره وفود فنيه لفتح السفارات
على وقع التوتر بين البرلمان والحكومه
الكويت تعيد مجلس الامه المنتخب عام 2020
ورئيسه السابق مرزوق الغانم
عبر 15 مسارا واكثر من 600 محطه اطلاق
المرحله الاولى من خدمه حافلات الرياض
وفي قطر النائب العام يامر باحاله وزير
الماليه السابق ومسؤولين اخرين الى محكمه
الجنايات لمواجهه تهم بالفساد
اهلا بكم من جديد نستهل نشرتنا من الرياض
حيث تشهد شوارعها اليوم سير حافلات النقل
ضمن المرحله الاولى من مشروع خدمه حافلات
الرياض والتي اعلنت عنها الهيئه الملكيه
ضمن مشروع الملك عبد العزيز للنقل العام
في العاصمه السعوديه الهيئه اوضحت ان
شبكتها حافلات الرياض سيبلغ مجموع اطوالها
بعد تشغيل المراحل الخمسه
1900 كيلو متر فيما سيزيد اجمالي عدد
الحافلات عن 800 حافله وستعمل عبر
686 مسارا تخدم الركاب عبر اكثر من 2900
محطه ونقطه توقف وستسهم خدمه حافلات
الرياض في تسهيل التنقل لجميع شرائح
المجتمع من خلال استخدام الحافلات كوسيله
للوصول الى اماكن العمل والتعليم والانشطه
الترفيهيه كما ستعمل على الحد من الحاجه
الى استخدام السياره الخاصه وبالتالي
تخفيف حده الازدحام المروري في الرياض
وبالتزامن مع اطلاق المرحله الاولى اطلقت
الهيئه البوابه الالكترونيه رياض باس دوت
اس اي التي تقدم خيارات متنوعه للركاب
لمعرفه مسارات الحافلات واليه شراء
التذاكر
المرحله الاولى من خدمه حافلات الرياض
تشمل 340 حافله عبر 633 محطه توقف تشمل 15
مسارا تبلغ مسارات شبكه الحافلات سته
وثمانين مسارا الرحله تكلف 4 ريالات لمده
ساعتين تبدا من تسجيل الدخول على احدى
الحافلات او التفعيل عبر التطبيق تمكن
التذكره صاحبها من الانتقال من حافله الى
اخرى خلال هذه المده
دعت المحكمه العليا في السعوديه عموم
المسلمين في جميع انحاء المملكه الى تحرير
رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان المبارك مساء يوم
الثلاثاء القادم ودعت المحكمه في بيان كل
من يرى الهلال بالعين المجرده او بواسطه
المناظير ابلاغ اقرب محكمه اليه وتسجيل
شهادته اليها او الاتصال باقرب مركز
لمساعدته في الوصول الى اقرب محكمه وتامل
المحكمه العليا ممن لديه القدره على
الثراء الاهتمام بهذا الامر والانضمام الى
اللجان المشكله في المناطق لهذا الغرض
واستعدادا لشهر رمضان المبارك بدات امانه
منطقه المدينه المنوره بالتعاون مع عدد من
الجهات الرسميه السعودي بتطبيق الخطط
التشغيليه للشهر من خلال تهيئه وسائل
النقل العام والنقل الترددي امانه المدينه
المنوره اعلنت ايضا عن تخصيص سته او سته
نقاط للنقل الترددي وخمس مواقع تشغيليه
فضلا عن استضافه الصائمين في موائد
الافطار في الاثناء بدات وكاله وكاله مجمع
الملك عبد العزيز لكسوه الكعبه باعمالها
استعدادا لاستقبال شهر رمضان حيث عملت على
صيانه كسوه الكعبه باستخدام تقنيات حديثه
كما عملت ايضا على تركيب قماش بارتفاع
ثلاثه امتار من جميع جوانب الكعبه
وبالعوده الى اطلاق المرحله الاولى من
خدمه حافلات الرياض من احدى محطات حافلات
الرياض انضم الينا مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز
اهلا بك معنا نواف انقل لنا صوره لديك
وكيف هي اول مرحله من تشغيل حافلات الرياض
نعم فاطمه كما ذكر رئيس الهيئه الملكيه
لمدينه الرياض للعربيه بدايه هذا العام في
منتدى دافوس بان المرحله الاولى من تشغيل
مشروع الملك عبد العزيز للنقل العام ستتم
في هذا الشهر بالفعل بدءا من صباح اليوم
الركاب يستقلون الحافلات
633 محطه ونقطه التوقف في الرياض بدات
بالعمل واستقبال الركاب بالاضافه الى
المسارات التي تعمل 15 مسارا ضمن المرحله
الاولى نحن الان نتواجد في هذه المحطه على
شارع التخصصي وهو واحد من الشوارع التي
شملتها المرحله الاولى من التشغيل وهو
شارع حيوي في الرياض من خلال هذه المحطه
سنحاكي الان رحله راكب الحافله بدءا من
الانتظار وشراء بطاقه
الصعود الحافله وانتهاء بالوصول الى
المحطه القادمه من خلال هذا الجهاز يمكن
اصدار بطاقه الصعود بطريقه سهله وايضا
بخيارات متنوعه سواء لشحن الاموال تبدا من
خمس ريالات وحتى مئه ريال يمكن اختيار اي
مبلغ والبدء بعمليه الدفع ومن ثم هناك
خيارات متعدده للدفع سواء نقدا او عبر
البطاقه المصرفيه او عبر محفظه
المحفظه الالكترونيه وهي بطاقه ضرب التي
نشاهدها الان وتستخرج بهذه الطريقه وهي
بطاقه يمكن لجميع الركاب اعاده الشحن
الخاص بالبطاقه واستخدام البطاقه عده مرات
بعد استخراج او اصدار هذه البطاقه مباشره
يمكن للراكب استقلال الحافله من خلال هذه
الحافله التي تتواجد جميع المحطات وتاتي
بشكل دوري تتوقف لدقائق اذا كان يتواجد اي
ركاب عند المحطه تقل الركاب وتنتقل الى
المحطه الاخرى سنبدا الان بالركوب الحافله
والانتقال الى المحطه
المقبله كما نعرف ان عمليه الدفع هي اربع
ريالات فقط لرحله بمده ساعتين تتم من خلال
هذه
جهاز الدفع الالكتروني وهو يتواجد في جميع
الحافلات نشاهد الان في هذه الحافله كيف
تجهيزات الحافله التي تمت على مدى سنوات
ونعلم ان الاختبارات التجريبيه لحافلات
الرياض تمت منذ اكثر من عام نشاهد هنا
اماكن مخصصه
للعائلات وايضا الافراد وذوي الاعاقه تنت
الحافلات بشكل سلس واؤكد ان اليوم لم يشهد
اي ازدحامات نظرا لان شوارع الرياض تعودت
على مرور الحافلات على مدى اكثر من عام
هذه المسارات تعتبر مرحله اولى 15 مسارا
340 حافله بالاضافه الى
النقاط التوقف والمحطات المجهزه باحدث
المعايير نتحدث عن كاميرات مراقبه ايضا
حتى الحافلات يمكن لجميع الركاب معرفه
مواعيد قدوم الحافلات بالاضافه الى معرفه
اي تفاصيل اخرى حول الحافلات وايضا محطات
الوصول هنا العديد من المنشات الحيويه
جاءت ضمن المرحله الاولى جامعه الملك سعود
ايضا مستشفيات بالاضافه الى الطرق
الرئيسيه هو اماكن التجمع
والمصانع التي يتوجه اليها من الكثير من
الموظفين بشكل مستمر في الصباح وفي
المساخل الفتره القادمه سنشهد اطلاق مراحل
اخرى وهي واحده من خمس مراحل وكما ذكرت
الهيئه الملكيه لمدينه الرياض بان
الاكتمال المشروع بشكل كامل والتشغيل له
سواء من قبل الحافلات او حتى قطار الرياض
سيتم بنهايه العام القادم
2024 واضح اذا رياض اس اي هو الموقع الذي
يمكن ان يزورونه
للمزيد من المعلومات حول مسارات الباصات
واين يمكن ان يستقلوا هذه الباصات نتمنى
لك رحله ممتعه نواف في هذا الباص شكرا
جزيلا لكم مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
خلال انعقاد ملتقى الاعمال السعوديه
التركي في السعوديه كشف وزير التجاره
التركي محمد موش عن ارتفاع النمو التجاري
بين انقره والرياض مؤكدا تواصل الجانبين
المستمر لدفع عجله الاستثمار موش اوضحها
ايضا ان بلاده تسير على خارطه طريق وضعتها
لدعم اقتصاد البلدين السعوديه وتركيا
وبالتزامن مع الملتقى انطلق في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض معرض الصادرات التركيه
لتعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين
اولا انعقاد ملتقى الاعمال السعودي التركي
في الرياض بحضور اكثر من 150 شركه وبقياده
معالي وزير التجاره وهذا الملتقى متخصص في
صناعه التشييد والبناء تعرف المملكه اليوم
تمر في في تحول غير مسبوق ونعيش ورشه عمل
الان وكثير من المشاريع الانشائيه فوجود
الخبرات الشركات التركيه ما في شك هذا
سيساهم في مرحله تحقيق رؤيه 2030 مثل هذه
الملتقيات وايضا اليوم في معرض اكسبو في
المساء العرض الصناعات والمنتجات التركيه
ما فيش شك تساهم في بناء العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
جميع الشركات خصوصا العامله في مجال
التشييد والبناء يتطلعون لفرص الاستثمار
في السعوديه وما نراه هنا هو التطور رؤيه
2030 حققت نموا كبيرا في كل المناطق حتى
جذبت الكثير من الاعمال والاستثمارات من
الخارج ومنها شركاتنا هنا لعقد شراكات مع
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
علقت على الحدود السعوديه الاماراتيه اكثر
من 500 شاحنه اردنيه محمله بالبضائع بسبب
عطل تقني وافادت وسائل اعلام بتعطل دخول
الشاحنات منذ ايام عبر منطقه جمرك البطحاء
السعودي بسبب عطل في انظمه
العملاء مخاوف بتلفي ما تحويه تلك
الشاحنات من مواد غذائيه وتموينيه واوضح
نقيب اصحاب السيارات والشاحنات الاردنيه
محمد الداود ان الشاحنات المبرده تستهلك
يوميا اكثر من 56 دولار من الديزل لتشغيل
محركات التبريد
عقدت الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني
اليوم الملتقى الوطني للامن السيبراني في
نسخته الاولى بحضور عدد من المسؤولين في
الجهات الحكوميه والخاصه وبمشاركه اكثر من
الف مختص في مجال الامن السيبراني يمثلون
اكثر من 500 جهه وطنيه في السعوديه وكشفت
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني خلال
الملتقى عن سته اطلاقات لتعزيز منظومه
الامن السيبراني في السعوديه شملت خدمات
استقصاء التهديدات السيبرانيه واضافه
خدمات جديده في البوابه الوطنيه لخدمات
الامن السيبراني حصين والبرنامج الوطني
للتوعيه بالامن السيبراني امن والنسخه
الثانيه من برنامج
لتنميه قطاع الامن السيبراني وبرنامج
الابتكار وغيرها
شهر رمضان هذا العام يبدا يوم الخميس
الموافق 23 من مارس وينتهي يوم الخميس
التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد الزعاج
[موسيقى]
منذ لحظه ولاده شهر شعبان والقمر يسير خلف
الشمس متجها من الغرب الى جهه الشرق
ويحاول بكل جديه ان يدرك الشمس وسيدركها
في تمام الساعه الثامنه واثنين وعشرين
دقيقه من مساء يوم الثلاثاء وفي ذلك
المساء سيغرب القمر قبل مغيب الشمس ولم
يولد بعد وحينئذ لا يوجد القمر البته بعد
مغيب شمس يوم الثلاثاء وبعد مغيب شمس يوم
الاربعاء سيكون له مكث قرابه الاربعين
دقيقه هذا من باب التقريب عالميا وعلى هذا
الاساس ستكتمل عده شهر شعبان 30 يوما
والخميس 23 23
اول ايام شهر رمضان الفضيل ورمضان لهذه
السنه سيبدا في يوم
ينتهي فيه فسيبدا يوم الخميس وينتهي يوم
الخميس ويوم الجمعه اول ايام العيد السعيد
اليوم يوم الجمعه مبارك ما اروعه يوم له
فضائل في ديننا مع رفعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والهلال لا يرى بالعين المجرده او بالعين
المسلحه الا اذا تحققت اركانه وتوافرت
شروطه فله ركنين ان يولد القمر قبل مغيب
الشمس وان يكون للقمر مكثم بعد مغرب الشمس
وشروطه ان يخرج من حي شعاع الشمس ومن حيز
الغبار والاتربه
وصفاء الاجواء تم الكلام وربنا محمود وله
المكارم والعلا والجود ثم الصلاه على
النبي محمد ما غرد قمري واورق
عودوا
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه الى العناوين
وزير خارجيه ايران يؤكد الالتزام باستقرار
المنطقه ويعلن الاتفاق مع السعوديه على
زياده وفود او زياره وفود فنيه لفتح
السفارات
على وقع التوتر بين البرلمان والحكومه
الكويت تعيد مجلس الامه المنتخب عام 2020
ورئيسه السابق مرزوق الغانم
عبر خمسه عشر مسارا واكثر من 600 محطه
اطلاق المرحله الاولى من خدمه حافلات
الرياض
وفي قطر النائب العام يامر باحاله وزير
الماليه السابق ومسؤولين اخرين الى محكمه
الجنايات
في امان الله
[موسيقى]